the whole thing quite incomprehensible
why i mean i want to see vape up there
with sort of on some kind of
hollywood type podium with lights all
over it but
in a way for me the whole point it was
at eight years old or something i mean
it's not what is the word of the year
that's what i wanted to catch up and
come into the mainstream i mean
last year for example certainly has
become a part of everyday parlance
hasn't it
indeed it has but i imagine it was
around for ages before i mean what we're
looking at are we not is publicity
and marketing and there is nothing at
all wrong with either of those things
and as truman capote put it the boy's
got to hustle his book
and so as a reference boy because
reference is in a lot of problems with
online
who's going to buy me my last dictionary
this is not to promote it was 6 200
pages long who wants to buy a 6 000
it does strike me though that you know
on that point of technology an awful lot
of these new words i mean vape for
example selfie are brought about because
of technology because technology lets
you do something you couldn't do before
and you've got to find a word for it if
you look through the lists of
words of the year over the last 10 20
years because they've been going for a
while now an awful lot of them are
indeed technological words like e hyphen
which was around for a while and a
variety but i think
the hard thing i find is what what makes
a word of the year is it that it sums up
a year or because most people have used
it or because it's sexiest what i mean
less sexy what is
and for me that's what that's where that
identifies isn't it yeah i mean one of
the other dictionaries are not oxford
chambers i think came up with over share
is the word of the year about you know
people giving uh what else was known as
tmi too much too much information
and probably regret it now and then
another dictionary another dictionary
gives us photo bomb yeah i mean are they
all going to scrap it out is there going
to be some referendum on vape versus
photobomb versus overshare versus normal
well the germans as well don't they
germans actually did it first i mean i
can't pronounce german but i believe
they got in there with something meaning
rebellion in 1971 am i looking back to
my old hippie days i think yes that
would have been about
not word of the year
once these words appear in the oxford
dictionary they're there then for good
aren't they
certainly the only well the oed the
oxford english dictionary the big one
the one that's i believe not even going
to be printed again because it's so
enormous yeah they're there because
that's what that kind of lexicon is
about
but a lot of dictionary they'll come
they'll go i did see a very sort of
cynical sake comment on twitter this
afternoon which said the word this year
is the one that won't exist in anybody's
memories next year but from my point of
view as alex corker some
one of my colleagues sent me a tweet
saying well it's like saying to a
carpenter what's your favorite nail
and i kind of feel like that people ask
me what my favorite slang word is
they're all my babies well all right but
just tell us about trends in slang i
mean what have you heard
over the last 12 months so you haven't
had before if you can say on air well
about almost what i can say is that it's
still about drugs and sex and rock and
roll i'm using all of those in the most
wide sense but curry i won't say it's
current again because it's been around
now for probably 10 12 years but is is
what's called multicultural london
english and this is this wonderful
interesting to me and i think a lot of
people blend it's what's used by teens
and 20s and it's a mixture of jamaican
patois of american hip-hop of the kind
of stuff you find in grime of cockney
can you give us an example oh well
there's some let's see jezzy for jezebel
and naughty girl also yeti there's
there's nang which means good and so on
and so forth i mean there's there is a
world of stuff bear is a very popular
one meaning lots of which is strange
because it sounds as if there should be
not many of but that's